[Music]
in 1984 i was in love with my first
grade teacher mrs farrell you had a
crush on your teacher when you were six
yeah i just
i had a crush on an adult wow yeah i had
a crush on annie i had a crush on a girl
who looked like annie i guess redheads
although my teacher wasn't a redhead
miss farrell couple years later i had a
crush on her daughter
oh you got around well nothing happened
with any of them
mentally you got around yeah oh mentally
i was on fire i was all over the place
later that year my first grade year my
crush transferred to somebody else
to me the the perfect girl corinne
martin she was
like an angel
like helena troy she she was she would
have launched a thousand
toy ships i guess because first grade
but um
i was
fascinated by her every move and then in
fifth grade she finally she approached
me i didn't i didn't have the courage to
go up to her she approached me on the
school bus on the last day of school and
gave me a note and i was so excited i
was like i was like squeezing and i was
a little bit it was like kind of
scandalous to me because what if
somebody saw and had a girl i'm
interacting with her i think i opened it
on the bus and she was kind of like
glancing back at me as i did and um
and it said
pam smart has a crush on you
oh it's better than stop staring at me
oh that's true it could have been a
season desist
it could have been a little like
makeshift restraining order
anyway um years later i ran into her in
las vegas and she has a family and she's
doing great and and you know what so am
i so it all worked out you've got a
podcast yes um and hopefully a family
soon
whoa whoa yeah that ticket is there
something you want to tell me well we'll
talk about it later life could be a
dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short i am
your at the moment
childless host justin long life could be
a dream
[Music]
uh with me as always is uh also
childless
brother christian um and you had crushes
i i remember wait don't tell me it was i
don't want you saying the name oh really
you may be comfortable outing your
crushes well i think it's a good thing
it's a positive thing i i would i would
never out somebody uh in a sh
anything shameful about somebody she was
the obstacle a personal thing
for me but not for oh really you're
saying well saying someone's name
publicly oh this is public oh yeah you
know if you feel com it's about you
feeling comfortable with it well no it's
also about the person like what if
corrine doesn't want me to yeah but it's
it's a very flattering thing you're just
saying you liked her i'm saying this and
i'm talking about her only because i
know i've kind of like already vetted it
in real life i've
like i said i ran into her in vegas and
she was i i told her
that's right i had a huge you know i've
no i was there but i've never told my
crush that i had a crush on her uh do
you do you remember how i reacted and
she reacted when i said i for a year and
i would think about her like after
school i remember the last time i really
saw her in school was like sometime in
high school you know and we had what to
her was probably a very innocuous
conversation about where you're going to
college and where you applied or
whatever but i remember it almost word
for word you were really in love with
her yeah she was your winnie cooper she
was she was and i used to think that
when i saw because we would watch every
week
was it fair to say it was our favorite
show there's one of them oh yeah the
wonder years yeah oh yeah and whenever
kevin arnold had anything to do with
winnie cooper yeah i related directly to
that and
yeah like you said
corrine was my winnie i liked life goes
on a lot too around that time yes but
wonder yours was the show wow both theme
songs were written by uh lennon
mccartney cool um but and winnie years
later danica mckellar the actress i got
to work with and um i
she was as lovely as i had always
imagined brilliant like a math matthew
she has a theorem named after her in
fact and um
that was such an important show to us i
mean we we
really was like um our we would wait i'd
wait every i remember being a little bit
depressed when it was over and in the
beginning how exciting that beginning
that opening the opening credits i won't
sing it's just i've seen it i've seen
the whole series
uh over again like a few times over the
last 20 years i've rewatched it multiple
times and i love it so much still it's
like
does it hold it like more than holds
yeah it's i think it's kind of the best
yeah it's like the best thing that's
ever been on tv yeah i mean there's
obviously like great comedies that i
love like seinfeld and curb enthusiasm
and the british office but like as a
show as like as a show
that has like drama and comedy of heart
and it you can't beat it no and and
even though it was about a different
time it was um
like we were a little you know
unfamiliar with that time obviously it
still was so relatable i mean it was
like oh yeah the writing was so good
that it was about these universal truths
about growing up and about uh change i
guess and
heartbreaking and and funny and god was
it good obviously if you haven't seen it
hopefully you should see it yeah it's if
you haven't seen it it's a show that
takes place in 1968 but they made it in
1988 20 20 years later yes and it runs
for uh five years and
but why are we talking about the wonder
years well i'll tell you why because
your wonder years well because the star
of that show um is are very
i can't say very enough or emphatically
enough special guest today uber
impressive yes
uber special sorry
fred savage
fred savage the star
of the one kevin arnold yeah and the
star of so many other great things when
we talk about princess bride and um
we didn't talk about little monsters but
uh he was a part of our childhood like a
really i would say a big part of our it
would be funny if you talked to fred
savage for an hour i mean you mentioned
you didn't mention the wonders but you
just talked about little monsters
i wonder if he'd say anything i wonder
if he'd be like uh are you sure we're
done
but he is such a nice guy and um
and was so game there was a part of me
that a few times thought and certainly
before thought like well i don't want to
dwell on it too much because
you know he's an adult now and he's
doing he's done such other so many other
great things and
is working constantly um he's mostly a
director now yeah as an adult he's
mostly been a director although he's
acted
uh he was on the show the grinder with
friend of the show rob lowe friends from
college yeah with the front of the show
another friend tara wasn't taran on that
no maybe not i don't think so yeah he's
but he's mostly a director he directs a
lot of tv he really enjoys directing but
he's done yeah all that great a lot of
great acting work and now he is
directing and executive producing the
new the wonder years it's a reboot of
the wonder years about a black family in
alabama in the same year 1968. it's out
now on abc and so fred we talked a
little bit about the new one but a lot
about the original because like we've
said way too much in this intro it was a
it was a huge show for us it was really
um special to us so uh this was as
special getting to talk to him getting
to know him a little bit it was a thrill
it was really surreal and um he could
not have been nicer you're about to hear
my my conversation with um a childhood a
part of my childhood and probably a lot
of yours fred savage
life could be a dream
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com
listen together
that's audible.com
slash listen together listen now only
from
audible hello
[Music]
fred
hi hey hey
how's it going justin this is so nice oh
my god you have no idea i'm gonna um it
might get a little weird i i'm so
excited to do this
yeah no i i hope i hope it does okay
wait
um i was so proud of myself because i
have a mic and everything uh-huh
i of course forgot the core so oh i
just ran down to the sound cart to get a
cord to plug in as long as the mic is
visible it doesn't have to work or
anything it'd just be nice to see it so
it looks like an actual podcast so
appreciate your commitment to just like
the visual routes of everything
um
it's just about the optics here after
our lives in show business justin
everything is make-believe everything is
exactly exactly
just
love
yeah yes yes exactly love respect yes um
integrity even now like however many
sets i've been on
anytime i lean on something a mailbox
and it falls over or i go to throw
something out and you know the the waste
paper basket is like has a cover on it
like it's blacked out
i'm always surprised
at how i still believe in the
make-believe of everything
and i'm also surprised and how i
continue to be surprised i i bet well
because
for you especially it must be
extra difficult i i guess to to divorce
yourself from that just because you grew
up on those sets i don't have that
experience like my formative years being
spent on
uh in that world in a world of
make-believe
yeah but you've done it enough yeah i
mean i mean it is like i know the
difference obviously i'm not an insane
person you know but
like my
my folks my wife always gets mad at me
because she's like i said
are you saying this
because you just to make me happy or
because you really mean it uh-huh i was
like what's the difference right right
right isn't it the same right like if
the result is yeah so who cares what my
intention is my intention is
don't look so close yeah yes don't
dissect my motives when when when the
end result is going to be the same
by the way going back to exactly that
like make believe there's no difference
you make in your life everything is a uh
long-form improv
so if you're just yes anding
that's how you say that's right that's
how you move forward
that's how you progress in the scene of
life is to
see that's exactly right well i think
that
and as a good actor it just means that
you're better at life
yeah um i uh nobody like you know you
you listen better yeah what i mean i
mean i'm also terrible at lots of things
in life but i'm good at improv well i'm
gonna think i'm gonna do a long-form
improv like weekly long like 85 years
yes that's the longest form
what's fascinating about you and
obviously so unique is that
you it struck me that you could do that
when you were a kid that you understood
just being present and listening just
like the basics that so few child actors
seem to be able to do do you remember
that feeling do you remember kind of
tapping into that as a kid and how how
like how did you do that i feel like as
a kid
like i have no um
don't now and so i didn't then have no
like real craft right like there's no
like there's no training or you know i
think over the years you take a little
bit of this and a little bit of that and
you read and talk to people but
especially as a kid i think what i love
so much about
other really great young performers is
there's such a freedom it's all game
playing and it's all
fun and naturalistic which is why when
you have like a young actor who's like
super coached it never feels quite right
because
i was just a lie i wasn't and so i could
just kind of be very freeing as a kid
and then when you get older
you know you start being much more
self-aware you get in your head
and that's when i think some craft is
really helpful but especially as a kid
i mean it was just kind of just it was
just fun there's like a purity to it
like um
the way the best acting is is just
listening and
and reacting and and i wonder if if it's
just that if it's just playing make
believe you get out of your own way
you're able to pretend
i just feel like that's that's kind of a
young former superpower it's just this
lack of any self-awareness
when it's really great and really pure
it's so freeing and i think audiences
kids and adults love it because it feels
so
immediate and unaffected and and pure
and i think a lot of the great young
performers were able to do that you know
when you look at i don't know whatever
your favorite performances from a young
actor are whether it's you know macaulay
culkin and home alone or
haley joe osmond you know anna or in
success or uh anna chumsky and my girl
i i don't know if they're the most you
know
you know uh
method based acting performances on film
but that's not why they're great you
know i mean that's not why they're great
they're great because they're raw and
messy and real and immediate and i think
the best young actors do that
one of yours was such a huge part you
were such a huge part of my
childhood my experience were roughly the
same age that i felt like
sometimes i to the point where i
conflate some of my own memories with
things that happened to kevin i was
watching some of the
the the first and third season episode
the one about the he goes you go up to
the lake and the
um
and and kara with kara and i i
remember thinking like oh i thought
my memories of my own upbringing are i
honest to god kind of conflated with
some moments on the wonder year so the
fact that people aren't coming up to you
and constantly validating you and your
role in their life is a surprise to me
people have always been great um
but i feel like
when i was aware that i like had
some i don't know talent
like it's still still i'll show you
i'll say for you so you don't have to
sound douchey and say when were you
aware that you were an incredibly gifted
young actor
like last thursday
okay well what happened i'm so
um it just all clicked and all yeah i
was like oh my god
just randomly
no i mean honestly my path was very
organic and very slow build and
i started doing commercials in chicago
uh it's where i'm from not because i was
wildly talented a scout didn't find me i
wasn't like it was
there were auditions being held adorable
yeah well they were
no one was like you got to be in
commercials it was like there were
auditions being held at the local
community center where i grew up for a
hot dog commercial
and so instead of going to the park that
day me and my friends our moms took us
to this audition did you want to go fred
were you like eager to go
uh yeah yeah but not like because uh
like i heard you could eat a hot dog
there you hot dogs i was gonna say yeah
and i was like oh yeah that sounds like
a great way to spend an afternoon it's
like why would i still do it for the hot
dogs yes yes yes god i remember once i
had
an audition when i was a little kid for
a payday candy bar commercial and i was
like
i still remember it i didn't even get
the job but i still remember being like
oh my god like i could eat hate candy
bars
that's really funny you were too um
excited about the candy bar in the
commercial maybe you were over the top i
was over the top i mean still today
food is
probably my key motivator for everything
i'm very like
a very primal like
every reward is food based everything is
to get like a slightly bigger pellet of
of good food and free pizza
anything whatever
um yeah
so uh so once i touch it i didn't get
the job and the director called me back
like six months later for um
uh oh the court is here oh
oh wow but check this out this is really
good this is good i thought you were
quoting the director for a second no
this is exciting that's that's not us
say hi
he's the best
she's the best um fred are you on an
elevated desk well always yeah are you
elevated right now can i go back to napa
i'm always on a deck i'm always about
four feet
higher
oh no no not a little podium napa is
terrified that i would put on camera so
she was kneeling he thinks i have a
podcast he's a quiet he's like wow are
you so much taller than her
you're there's nothing oh hey okay
she was she's terrified uh that i'll put
like she'll be on something on oh that's
hilarious it's like the opposite of you
were when you were a kid uh yes it's
also the opposite of her i think she
really wants to be on camera oh
[Laughter]
does she have a performance background
um she is an nyu film grad um okay as a
director but also um
sure she was in a few of those student
films and didn't mind it she's very
she's very talented very challenging
oh boy this is exciting so fred is
plugging in a new phone a new phone new
microphone that napa has delivered then
how
um all right so let me get back to the
director
commercial
so the director calls you back six
months later for um for the same uh
for another audition and uh this time it
was downtown so i was really excited i
never got to go downtown i lived in the
suburbs and i didn't get that job but
that was fun because i got to go
downtown and then six months later the
same director called me for a job
another audition and my mom like we
didn't know like
we didn't know people auditioned like
for years to get a job like before
anything happens and she's like you know
we've already been at two of these
things oh that's so funny um like i this
seems like a real waste of time like
we'll just ask try to ask for that
and so um
it was for pac-man vitamins and this was
in like
1983 or something like there couldn't
have been anything bigger than pac-man
vitamins or than pac-man and so i was
like pac-man i heard that i was like
yeah let's go
and i got that job
you know at the time
now chicago is is huge but at the time
there wasn't a lot of production but all
the ad agencies were based in chicago so
there was a lot of commercial work like
leo burnett's there and bbdl like
everything was based in
uh chicago so there was a lot of work
and i kind of became one of these kids
that did a lot of commercial work and
that's kind of where i started but it
was very like gradual slow builds that's
so funny fred that she almost bailed
after the two failed i mean for you know
for anyone who's been an actor or
attempted to be an actor it's like two
is nothing that's no people auditioned
for years but we didn't i remember
meeting this really there was a friend
this guy that was dating a girl i knew
in l.a really handsome australian guy
like kind of hunky australia he was like
i was talking to him at a party i
remember this is like 10 15 years ago
he's like yo i'm going to give myself
like you know it's been like he seemed
really down about the career he's like
yeah
i figured i could come over here and
start start working and i haven't worked
and it's been like you know three weeks
it's been like two three weeks so i'm
gonna give it another couple of weeks
and like see what happens but otherwise
i'm going back and i remember thinking
like what two three week that's insane
uh it was chris hemsworth
and like a week later he got thor and i
was like well
he did say it was within his win
you know look you got to have barriers
three weeks like if i like when i was
building like a directing career you
know that also was a kind of a slow
build
three or four weeks between jobs was
like
awesome like i was because then you
could like say what are you doing
because like the worst answer is
someone's like what are you doing like
ah nothing like that's the worst like
you can't say that right so like what
are you doing well
i got this thing coming up and you could
say coming up for like probably two
weeks you know what i mean and then like
true there's like the week that you're
doing the thing and then like for two
weeks after you'll be like well i just
did i have a thing i just did a thing
and so
you can and
like how long ago i don't know like last
thursday like you can definitely
as long as i had a job every like five
to six weeks i could string that out so
i didn't sound like an [ __ ] i i know
sometimes people catch me off guard with
that when i haven't done a thing or i
don't have a thing coming out or it's
just embarrassing to talk about a thing
that you have you know it's just like i
don't wanna it sounds like it's
inherently bragging so if somebody says
well what do you have going on now i
more often than not say like make some
self-deprecating joke about oh nothing
i'm not doing anything yeah i i i
i you yeah because you don't want to be
the person who's like well i gotta you
know spitting a lot of wheels but when i
was yeah i feel more comfortable saying
that now but like in like my 20s and 30s
i i wanted to oh i want to be like this
hotbed activity and uh and so i could
like i could string like one
five or even like two day job
i could have that
cover like that'll last yeah
yeah
what what so how did then you go from
so you become like kind of a major
player in the commercial world in
chicago oh yeah well how how then did
movies happen was it
and i can't wait to talk about princess
bride obviously but but what was the
first thing what was uh the first movie
i did a movie and there's there was a
local
and this is the same for princess wright
actually there's a local casting
director in chicago his name is ken
carlson great great guy and you know
cast uh
you know a lot of the commercial you
know big cat commercial casting director
there but also would cast films as they
would come to chicago and so i
auditioned for this movie called the boy
could fly that was my first move
and ken carlson knew me from chicago as
being one of the kids who who did a lot
of work and i you know i got a job from
there and by the way same with princess
bride like i think it was jane jenkins
like classic oh yeah uh amazing you know
just a classic legendary casting
director i think that all of rob reiner
stuff was the casting director but can
as you know like you know big movies and
i'm sure your audience knows at this
point
know more about show business than i
probably do but like you know big movies
when they do like a nationwide
search they you know have there's a cash
director for the film but then they have
someone in philadelphia and someone in
boston and someone in new york and
someone in chicago kind of doing their
local casting that then would feed up to
the main cast director so ken
did the local
casting in uh in chicago
you know auditioned with ken and then
met rob and and then
run from there something like that
because rob i think he'd already done
stand by me right which was kind of
which was a head and
spinal tap yes he done stand by me and
spinal tap and sure thing
um
uh
you know and it was in that like you
know his run you know is just legendary
from from sure thing through like
american president is just unrivaled
just haymakers like no filmmaker ever
has made that many phenomenal movies
genres
uh it's just incredible but yeah it was
at the beginning of that like at your
age at the time are the stakes higher to
you are you feeling more pressure um
when you're pursuing a child like that
no not then not then as a kid i mean i
was like i was like i don't know i was
maybe nine
nine or ten wow
so to you it's just like wow it's
another it's another thing that i might
get which is fine well for me
uh for that one i remember
they shot the film at shepparton in
london
and so and so that's where they shot all
the all the exteriors and uh was all in
the uk and they built all these
incredible stages in london so i got to
they shot our stuff in london because
that's just where the crew was so i got
to go to london and i was like that's
awesome so that for me that was like
you know if this travel shoot in london
and that was very cool to me so that was
that was a bigger deal than meeting
peter falk or or or rob rider did you
know who peter falk was when you were
nine
no no my parents did
but
but
after that he was so nice to me he was
so nice i remember
he just yeah i mean just the best he was
so warm and then a few years later
a couple years later i started on the
wonder years and it was on abc around
the same time that they brought back
colombo they did that columbo they would
do like like four specials a year for
many years yeah yeah and i kind of know
that um
i would see him you know at like up
fronts and abc cast things
and you know
up until he passed away any time i saw
peter falk he just couldn't have been
warmer or a more special guy i just have
such a
special place in my heart for him he
just was so kind to me and
i just love that guy love them whenever
i think of peter faulk i think of that i
think i just hear him go looking for
this glasses
yeah was was that
was that do you remember was that
improvised
i think okay okay
i don't think it was scripted and i i
don't know if it was
improvised or a note but it i the thing
i
love most about it
then and even more so now as a parent is
just
i think it might have been both i
definitely think he was such an
incredible
improviser and always just so in the
moment but um
finding any excuse to spend one more
second with someone you love yeah yeah
that's really beautiful that's true
that's true oh god that's a great way of
looking at that moment
that's how i always saw that and
you know i have kids of my own and you
say goodnight to him and even now like
you know my oldest is 15 15 13 and eight
and uh if you have some any moment of
connection with your kids yeah um you
know whether it's reading them a story
or
watching some great video on you know uh
or just talking to them there's any
these moments of connection are so deep
and meaningful
and increasingly rare you know as they
get older but you just want to just
drink every second i bet that's really
beautiful wave
yeah oh man i'm going to think about
that when i see that moment because i
see it every time it's on tv um
that's how i felt like he just didn't
want to go yeah
yeah yeah but it just didn't wanna yeah
yeah
and and he's not the kind of guy he's
not from that generation certainly that
would say
that would show affection in in an overt
way you know that would say yeah i love
you so much you know whatever it is yeah
that's beautiful to think about it that
way god is that beautiful um what what
do your kids think of uh certainly that
movie they must have seen but i guess
more so the wonder years because it's
like that must be extra strange for them
only because it's um
you get to see this person's life like
this this character's life
at their age now my mom she would show
that so
really um which was which was so cool
uh but i think that um
they like it i think they enjoy you know
you had mentioned like people coming up
to me and you know people
have it's kind of similar
to you in that i feel like you and i are
fortunate
to have played people
that people like you know i mean like
it's all character it's like characters
that people like that's right it's right
non-threatening
yeah not not dicks not threatening not
just just like
just
and so i i don't know i'd be interested
to hear your experience but for me
whatever and even the stuff like i shoot
behind the camera it's it's it's
their comedies they're fun and so people
who
um
approach me it's always
it's always warm you know like it's
always warm and uh not bad
or or even if they don't know exactly
who i am
they make like maybe it's like they
think like i you went to high school
together like they're not quite sure but
they know they have like a positive
affiliation with me yes and so
so much so i think my kids as that
translates to my kids like
i think they're uh they like that
people know me and that people are warm
and i think they see the best of it in
that
people
like the stuff i do like it's they
either enjoy it or in some cases it's
actually meaningful to them and i think
they really i think they like that do
you find that is that for you i mean
that must be the same i think so i you
know i also think sometimes the the
opposite i was just talking to my
brother about this which is that because
we have this movie coming out and he
made the mistake of reading we both did
of reading comments about the trailer
and
a big mistake and um
and so we were talking what was the
gamut though what was the game you know
people there were nice things but that's
i don't know if you feel this way but i
am
uh the way i think is that uh you know
nice things i don't really absorb them
they're they're they're nice to hear and
but no only that means things are true
you know the mean things are true and
stick you know because that's people who
really are telling you like i know it's
ridiculous and i wish i weren't wired
this way but um i we were talking about
this this
the the idea that that there are people
in the world who who've never met me
who hate me
who who express their derision online or
whatever but but regardless of how they
express it like on a deep like cellular
level oh i've read things from i want to
punch him in the i've read like
terrible i don't go on twitter anymore i
don't read that stuff but but um there
was a time so i know i'm aware that in
the world there are people right now in
the world who hate me i mean to varying
degrees
and that writes me out a little bit
um i have two thoughts on that that
might be helpful
i don't know if this is
misattributed i i've always heard it was
uh treated to louis armstrong it might
not have been but i really live by it
which is uh
if everyone likes what you're doing
you're not making strong enough choices
oh that's great i really believe that
that's great i really believe it yeah um
because you have a point of view you
know that's you know you know you and
your brother have a point of view that
are valid and uniquely yours and that's
your superpower is is the unis of of you
you make choices with that lens and
hopefully strong choices and
yeah not everyone's gonna love it and
the other thing is i don't believe any
of it like like i don't i definitely
don't believe the good and i'm also not
so
crazy
to only believe the bad like i just
don't believe any of it you mean like if
you don't invest in it no i don't invest
in like i don't ride the highs like i
think that's all baloney such a great
perspective but was there a time that
you did i mean did you have to it was
there an evolution there did you have to
no i mean i feel like i always grew up
with some sense of blinders on as far as
like my public persona you know
uh you know i i
none of my friends were in show business
my my family wasn't uh you know we
weren't a big show business family i
mean my brother eventually got into it
but like we weren't like a show we
didn't hang out with show business
people and so i didn't really i wasn't
in like that echo chamber that just like
feeds and builds and builds it was very
like well that's what you know fred does
and then i had friends who had their own
things was that difficult for your
parents did your parents really go out
of their way to
like cultivate that to curate that kind
of life i mean i i'm sure yeah i'm sure
they must have but the result was like
i had no i didn't have like a super
inflated sense of of myself or
so all that like
noise that was out there was literally
just noise like
um
it probably would have been way harder
to block that stuff out as a kid you
know with social media so the people who
are navigating it now are
operating at such a much higher
level of emotional and intellectual
awareness uh i i don't know how they do
it it's incredible fred you talked about
people coming up to you and being very
nice um but my experience with you like
i said is so it feels so personal to me
just because um that show was so huge in
my life and we always look forward to it
and loved following that character do
people ever when they do approach you is
it ever
overly familiar i would imagine people
are very
familiar have the experience that i do
which is like they feel like they know
you
i'd have to really think about it but
nothing pops out as like nothing ever
was uncomfortable or weird it was always
just like oh hey like it was always just
very
friendly like i'm not the
kind of famous that it would there's
like a
you know the general public presents a
danger like you know that was a great
episode of like um
i think of your seinfeld episode too oh
yeah great seinfeld appearance maybe
that's in my head that kramer like a
costume
that was
that's probably as bad as it got that's
as bad as a guy okay okay
the the timing of that scene of the your
exit it's one of the greatest exits i've
ever seen because you have to first of
all not laugh when he's
going wild i mean he's like falling
uh he's false on a table it's huge and
all real and um the two of you together
are so
[ __ ] funny in that scene but your
exit is so smooth how long did that take
to choreograph like how much rehearsal
was there i mean
you've done multi-cams like you know i
was there for like an hour
so it's like amazing uh but i heard that
michael richards he he's really intense
about i mean all of those move they have
to be or he'd get injured but he's with
his com like physical stuff the thing
about michael then was i i remember very
distinctly he didn't the scene uh
uh was you know he was was trying to
pitch me a script um it was very nervous
to meet me
and so um
he didn't want to meet me before so i
met like oh you know
david was there and you know jerry
seinfeld was there and um yeah i didn't
meet the other actors it was just me and
uh cramer but
michael richards wanted to like keep it
you know uh oh funny uh method fresh
yeah which i which i totally respected
but yeah it's so funny you mentioned the
exit because that's the one thing i
remember is larry was just like get out
of there usually
just just get out like i'm like but i
have these lines that he goes it doesn't
matter oh like just because
he's like just go just just just get the
hell out it's so smart yeah and i was
like oh okay i love like no one's broken
it down like that to me like the way you
just have and
that's all larynx you need to just get
the hell out kramer's so nervous that
it's like it's scary it's like
threatening
[Music]
if you're having trouble sleeping which
i often do plus cbd can help daily use
plus cbd sleep gummies get you the rest
you need so you can wake up feeling
focused and refreshed formulated by a
team of medical experts and doctors plus
cbd sleep gummies taste great and are
made with award-winning cbd combined
with melatonin magnolia bark and lemon
balm cbd calm gummies are perfect for
daily relaxation i had one yesterday and
to help support a sense of calm when
you're feeling overwhelmed and are made
with a blend of cbd
l-theanine and 5-htp if those things
mean nothing to you
join the club join the club also the cbd
sleep gummies are great for sleep
support which combine the soothing
properties of cbd with melatonin
magnolia bark extract and relaxing lemon
balm reserve collection is a specially
curated blend of full spectrum
cannabinoids that celebrates our very
first batch of plus cbd oil the reserve
collection gummies with 25 milligrams of
cbd and 2.5 milligrams of thc elicit
feelings of calm and relief when intense
support is needed sleep better tonight
why not just visit plus cbd oil.com
and enter promo code long for 40 off
your order that's 40 percent off and
that's also code long at plus cbd oil
dot com for 40 off
[Music]
another thing re-watching these episodes
that strikes me as
not only were you so good but god
[ __ ] dan lauria and
abby mills the your parents uh jason
hervey and olivia dabo the whole family
was so
the acting is so good on that did it
start to feel like a family i i know
that's such a cliche thing to to say
about
a long-lasting show but it felt so real
um how did you perceive
dan uh and abby in real life um they
were
great they were great and yeah i mean it
is
i think like lots of
great cliches they become that way
because they kind of are true in a lot
of ways so i do think that um
it did feel very familial also because
it was such a you know such a seminal
time in my life i was on that show from
when i was i think i was like 11 when we
did the pilot and i was
16 or 17 when we finished and so
you can't help but build those
connections yeah um
but uh they were all yeah they're all
incredible actors yeah um and and dan
really uh i think kind of planted in my
head very early on that like i could be
a director you know he he would show me
old movies we'd talk about filmmaking
like he he instilled in me a whole love
of of classic film and directors and you
know saturday on the weekends i'd go to
his place where he'd come to mind we'd
watch old movies and i loved that and
and really started to think
that maybe i could in terms of a
director at a very early age like on his
encouragement
well that that's
those episodes are so well directed too
i mean you must have been
you were able to absorb uh
the work of so many
great tv directors there's this shot i
i've forgotten some of this it's also so
patient when you compare it to today's
tv there's that shot where they go into
the cemetery it's it's at brian's
funeral brian cooper's funeral and it's
this wide wide shot of a cemetery that
just slow it's beautiful it's like and i
it's to some great song some bob dylan
um but um
it struck me that the direction some of
the directors were
you got to be
yeah yeah no there was there was some
great direction and i like what you
think about um
it was patience you know i feel like
there's so many comedies and i i love
all you know i love all of it it's not
one's good or what's bad but there's you
know terrific comedy that is very like
just everything's just cut like um
there's just no air and and that's one
of the things that makes it so great is
that it's so relentlessly funny
uh that you don't have a second to catch
it and i love that but i think the
wonder years um and i think you know
this version this version we're trying
to do now
um
you know the original was certainly very
patient um
there were you could let moments breathe
um and we're trying to try to do the
same thing here oh that's good to hear
fred i was going to ask you i that's
good to hear because i that's not
doesn't feel like the style anymore um
and and and i like that i like quick
quippy stuff too but
the older i get maybe it's just a sign
of my age is that i need to sit with
something sometimes and i and and and
life isn't like that i always find
things more funny when it's closer to
when it's real you know like that moment
on seinfeld where like
you know you just have you want to get
out of there your intention is clear and
um and that's what the wonder years felt
like it felt um
and i love the moments of silence on the
one year and of course
daniel stern's like incredible narration
is such a huge part of it
was that was that a challenge for you
guys did did it ever feel like an
unusual amount of time that you had to
wait because obviously you know the
narration
wasn't there while you were shooting it
which i'm now imagining would be really
funny well
certainly the narration in the script
that's bait that that gives you that
time yeah i mean so yeah that is it's
kind of baked in which was made one of
the things one of the very positive
things about the narration was that
it gave you that space um did they how
would they how would they do the timing
i mean would they read would you just
have it in your head there no there was
uh an onset narrator
whose job was just to read the narration
oh well
and he was his name was kirk truthner
and he did it for
pretty much the whole run
and uh
he was you know incredibly valuable
uh our relation you know for everyone
because he would read it in real time so
you'd have all the spacing um but then
he was you know for me it was like
another scene partner because
you know
he read it
he didn't just read it you know i mean
like he read it with emotion like he
he um
he performed it and that allowed me to
kind of you know react along with him
but he was he was awesome
like a totally invisible but
integral part of the uh the whole thing
wow yes that and some of the the writing
on that i've been writing it down it's
just so poetic and beautiful especially
the closing
little thoughts the closing narration is
always
so profound and touching um yeah there
was some killer stuff they did a good
job god beautiful
what um do you have a favorite episode
fred when you look back at the show um
that's a great question i um it was one
of the first season
oh where i went to my father's office i
loved that one because i remember going
to my dad's kid i loved it yeah
heartbreaking yeah um that was so
relatable too because i remember that
too going to my dad's office and how
cool it was that he had like a there was
a secretary and like there were pens
that you could just take for free and
like they're all in the swivel chair all
that it was like
i went to the xerox machine zx machine
even as an adult i'm still like oh
that's awesome they're so bad
um
so i love that one there was one where
um
my math teacher died there was a great
arc of the math teacher and when he died
was very memorable for me he was a great
actor that guy i remember stephen
gilborn
um
wonderful actor and that's the other
thing like that show and i'm so glad you
mentioned the cast
the supporting cast the the teachers and
the friends and
um
it was just everyone was
everyone was just so
good and
real and um
carla
was great
yeah oh my god oh yeah people at the
beginnings of their careers whether it's
carla carla gagino david schwimmer john
corbett alicia silverstone there's so
many
um
who are amazing i think that's one of
corbett's best to this day i mean i love
corbett uh he's uh he's hilarious um but
god that [ __ ] dinner table scene yeah
that stuff you don't see on tv anymore
that a real discussion about war and
about the price of westbrook i mean it's
it's sadly still so timely
that um
many shows oh god what am i'm getting
chills thinking about it uh and we're
doing it you know it's it's i understand
how hard that is to do
to maintain that because even you know
now on this version that we're doing
now
uh there's
such an impulse and such a pull
from
uh you know marketing publicity and the
network in the studio and and some part
of your own mind to go to like a known
person or a celebrity for this role
and uh
you know it really takes
some discipline and
a real clarity of purpose to want to
find those actors because
i think it made him it made it so
special on on uh on the first one and
we're trying to do the same thing here
it it made it so much easier to to
accept that it was real that it was
yeah you were never yeah yeah cause the
whole show is about memory and
connecting with your past and seeing
your own experiences and experience of
the actors so if you're watching it and
all of a sudden
you know whoever comes along
um
i think it does yeah it makes it
it just disconnects
memory
and and fred how is it difficult to
navigate the
what we just talked about i mean like
talking about really real issues and
like heavy issues um
done through the lens of this kid of
course but but nonetheless i mean like
those were some one of yours dealt with
some really serious heavy stuff is is
that difficult in today's landscape i
mean is it difficult to do that now on
network tv
i think uh both for
the show i'm doing now the version of
wonders i'm doing now and and and the
first one um
you know be setting it 1968
it's with purpose you know there's
there's incredible change incredible
turmoil it's a country coming of age not
just the kids
so uh
you know it um
it's very fertile
ground
but at the same time what's going on out
in the world
only becomes part of the storyline
insofar as it penetrates the you know
the world of a 12 year old which for the
most part kind of ends at your nose you
know or
or or how far your parents will let you
ride your bike from home like that's
that's the end of your whole world right
right so if something penetrates that
then you really it really resonates but
outside of that you're not so aware of
what's going on in the world that's true
even that dinner table scene with dan
laurie and corbett
i i mean it's it's really the thing that
strikes kevin arnold is that his dad has
kind of lost control a little bit and um
and and that that was jarring that was
that was a new shocking thing and that
lost his daughter really or like you
know you know in the in the first one
the vietnam war
really didn't penetrate his experience
until you know the guy next door died
until winnie cooper's brother died and
even so that was when he's like oh yeah
there's something going on
you know over there even then what's
great about that is that he um he still
just wants winnie i mean i remember that
ex like the the the focus is still on
the scene at the wake is like it's it's
funny but it's also so real is that
you're struggling with
has enough time passed am i being
insensitive by by liking her you're like
struggling with the guilt of that of
still like being attracted to her while
she's grieving it's it's like brilliant
yeah but real it's exactly right there's
there's another episode that really i
think encapsulates that is he's uh he's
trying to call this girl he's obsessed
with calling us oh yeah that he really
likes and then the moon landing is going
on in the other room
and
that's not what's important to him you
know to a 12 year old or a 13 year old
yeah you got to call this pr this cute
girl from school right right and you're
building it up in your head and
uh so telling those stories like to
answer to try and answer your question
like telling those stories
um in today's landscape yes it's
difficult um i also think it's even more
important to not shy away from those
difficult stories
but
the conceit of the show
allows you to
explore them a little more obliquely
because
it's it's through this lens of right a
kit
but it but also um
through a very it's got to be a
different lens i mean like the the
experience of a young black kid
has to be different than
a white kid's experience was
how involved can you be in that like
is it is it ever
do you ever not want to give notes
because of what different experiences
you've had
i have incredible partners on the show
right uh you know lee daniels is one of
the executive producers um
saladin patterson um is the writer and
showrunner and creator and he's writing
all from his own experiences
and so
uh and then you know our department
heads you know when we when we were you
know hiring production designers and
costumers and you know they weren't
pulling references from
the internet or getting images they were
pulling references from their own photo
albums you know and that's cool this is
this is what my grandfather's living
room looked like and this is the outfit
my aunt wore to church and and so
there's so much there's so many
wonderful
partners and collaborators that are
bringing this sense of authenticity to
the storytelling and to the visual
landscape
um and for me
i feel like it's my job i'm kind of
applying my years of experience as an
actor and as a director
to trying to bring saladin's story um
you know to life and so you know with
sal wisley with these other
collaborators
um who have
a deeper more visceral connection to the
lived experience of these characters
um with them as kind of these guiding
forces we can you know build this world
and tell the story
i can't wait to see it
is it shot in the same is shot in the
same like vicinity that you shot your
stuff at the same studios and stuff this
is um i'm in atlanta we're shooting it
oh oh okay the show takes place um where
uh
saladin uh is from tuskegee alabama and
so
the show takes place in montgomery oh
wow okay and so yeah it's it's it's it's
uh well which was like the hotbed of i
mean talk about change in 1968 like it
doesn't get more yes volatile and
african-american family in 1968 in uh
montgomery alabama so that's our that's
our setting but you know this so so you
know the setting the characters it's all
different and unique um to the show
what's similar and what i think i can
bring is
the tone that you and i were talking
about you know um the the
the pace you know the
sense of this kind of sense of
having one toe in
you know comedy and one toe and very
real you know truth-telling experience
about about growing up um the sense of
nostalgia the narrator the sense of
looking back on your childhood with the
wisdom of of age
is that being done the same way a
similar way like like you described kurt
on your
set is there somebody reading that
narration for the young adult there is
there's a guy named brian who's here who
uh i was like if we're gonna do this
it's essential
to not have you know a lot of times when
you're on a set um
i'm sure you've experienced it there's a
vo for whatever reason the supervisor
reads it or the ad reads it or the
director will read it but often very
well someone was that was that often
often very woodenly oh yeah with the
monotone and just yeah um
but i wanted someone to have the same
experience that i did and and uh let's
meet it with emotions we have this
wonderful reader um so though so those
that's kind of what i can kind of bring
is
uh making this kind of um
a a tonal and
um kind of spiritual cousin to the first
one but at the same time telling
entirely different and unique stories uh
that's exciting it must be exciting for
you too and especially like um now doing
this completely a related but um very
different thing in your life like things
coming full circle for you
it is cool
it's it's both
incredibly familiar and
uh like you know you know putting on a
great pair of jeans or something but
yeah it's also
totally new and exciting and um uh you
know scary and and all those things that
get you excited and uh and
and pumped for something will there be
any uh like cameos like little easter
eggy cameos from the original series
like jason herbie showing up as a
teacher or something you know it's hard
because it's the same year um and so i
don't think any of us are going to be
making cameos right right but also talk
about taking you out of it like it was
yeah
um i uh but but i think we're we're
gonna we're gonna drop little there's
gonna be some little moments of
connective tissue um that i think will
be really uh really satisfying oh cool
well i am so excited i don't wanna take
too much of your time i i know um i've i
already have you're being very generous
um but i have to ask you about uh danica
i worked with danica mckellar um oh god
20 years ago now and it was so hard to
separate i'm sure
you and she have discussed this it was
hard for me to separate her from
my experience of watching her and like
falling in love with her and and uh i
remember when she told me her sister was
the same actress who played becky slater
yes blew my mind i had blew my mind was
and you must be so sick of
answering questions like this but
i'm sorry did you was there ever a time
where you had a crush on danica was
there ever any like
was that difficult it just felt so real
that if the answer is no please don't
tell me um i will tell you that
i think danica i think the character
uh as written
and then as played by danica
represented this ideal for
everybody you know this this untouchable
just perfect ideal and danica
that's a lot for a young woman and now a
woman to carry um but uh
you know our relationship was always
um you know incredibly professional and
and warm yeah but um
but uh
i mean she i don't think there's anyone
who
uh myself included who who didn't look
at danica as this
this um
this ideal of everything we could want
or hope for in a in a girlfriend
and as it turns out danica's like you
know this but i'm telling people that i
i was playing like a math genius in this
thing and she was playing like a
cheerleader next door and in real life
she she had to help the um the art
director with some of the mathematical
problems because she's like a map she's
a math genius she literally is a math
genius she like wrote a theorem that
she's the name that i try to explain to
me several times i still don't
understand really but like she heard the
world lecturing on this theorem and now
she's also written she's like a
best-selling author and it's written
honestly i think it's at this point like
seven or eight like best-selling math
books that are geared towards kids and
and mathematics it's amazing that's
great and another um
kirk mcrae uh played by
the wonderful michael landa michael's a
friend of mine michael landis and i
still see him he's the best you see him
oh really yeah the best
yeah a lot of this hey what's up about
it that uses i love the way he uses his
hands when he talks
we've i've i've directed him with since
he's an actress as adults and um
we uh our kids join the same uh ayso
soccer league who are there yeah
this is the best the best what do people
do people see you interact together and
do they get as i would get um make
references
uh
i don't think as you would as i'm
getting you know
okay
cool
[Laughter]
maybe
maybe
um okay i realized now i'm going to take
that as a cue to move on no no no no
you're not look your knowledge is deep
and your passion it really warms my
heart i love it i feel it i really it
makes me so happy just tonight like
honestly
no well well you've made me so happy
over the years so um yeah i i it's it's
it's nice to be able to talk to you
about it you had talked about people
playing these nice guys and doing it so
effectively that people treat you a
certain way
was was
was that why you did you make a
conscious
choice then to do a movie like rules of
attraction uh which you're so good in
you're so
that was shocking to me when i saw that
because you were you're playing the the
opposite of a kevin arnold type uh was
that conscious was that something that
you felt like you had to do
uh you know it wasn't something that i
had i didn't feel like i had to do it um
but i i uh when the opportunity
presented itself i was really really
excited about it i was really excited
about to do something different but it
wasn't like a reaction against anything
okay yeah yeah or a move towards
something it was more just like oh what
a cool fun
opportunity i mean it's so funny people
remember that scene it's so cool but i
was really leaning into it like um
like that was my clarinet i played
clarinet at the time really so funny i
brought it to set being like hey is this
something like
and roger was like oh my god that's i
remember roger's that's awesome let's do
it and so like i i i was really leaning
into the the the fun of playing uh that
scene for sure and and probably getting
to improvise in as this character is
kind of like a degenerate um you know
you're like on crazy drugs you're
falling asleep in the scene
i was really into it i remember i
brought like i brought some clothes like
i brought like a i was really excited to
wear uh fedora
no i was in nothing i was in underwear i
was like right yeah you were smoking i
remember ashes going on your belly yeah
i held the cigarette in my belly
yeah
to play the clarinet but it was so fun i
mean it was fun to do stuff like that
was was there improv um was there room
for improv on the wonder years or was it
pretty heavily scripted that was pretty
tightly scripted that was very very
tightly scripted
and uh you know the writers really
wanted it kind of like letter perfect so
that was that was very thoughtfully
crafted
um when you went to stanford you went to
stanford after
uh wonder years ended were you already
interested in directing were you already
on the path to wanting to be a director
just
and and if so was that just your
curiosity about what you were witnessing
on set
yes
to both like i was i was already really
interested in it and i thought it might
be something i'd want to do as an adult
and uh and it was all born from being on
set and being so interested in
everything from you know the creative
decisions that went into crafting a
scene you know why
the choices the director would make um
to just like the mechanics of it like i
just thought a camera was cool you know
we were shooting on film and
i loved watching load the thing and
check the gate and look for the hairs
and that like as a machine yeah you know
it was just mechanically so cool and i i
love that uh
and so i was just so interested in all
of it so yeah it was all born there was
it was it ever weird fred reentering the
real world after after certainly after
having such success on on tv like having
fame having a taste of fame
did it i mean we talked about this a
little bit but specifically going back
to school like going back to a regular
high school and then to stanford
was there ever a strange adjustment
you know i uh
i feel like you know even though i
wasn't
because i wasn't working anymore i mean
it certainly was not the real world i
mean i was away in school and like it
was definitely that's true we were
cloistered away that's true um like it
wasn't like it wasn't like living on the
hard streets really getting getting in
touch with life yeah um
but i wasn't working
i was saying like at school
um
it was one of the things i really
liked about it is that uh
like i was i was just like one of the
normal i was just a regular kid like i
wasn't um
like kind of everyone at stanford was
kind of extraordinary in some in some
way like
you know my room my neighbors like one
guy was like the reigning world champion
for wiffle ball was like a world wiffle
ball champion and this other guy was
like whoa toning the tuberculosis you
know
germ to to find a cure like during the
summers like everyone she's well that's
more impressive way more yeah i mean but
they everyone like tiger woods was in my
senior class my freshman year and oh
reese witherspoon was like a year behind
us and i really enjoyed just stand out
no that way no no and i and and i i i
like that yeah was ben's ben becoming an
actor just kind of like was he going on
these auditions with you and was just
like i imagine your parents just being
like well fred's busy but i do have
another very talented son
fortunately they kept their their roles
to parenting which was good yeah yeah
that sounds like that but you know my me
and my brother and i we have a i have a
sister
who um
is really the talented one like she like
did a plays at lincoln center and
won awards as an actress and
now that she got her msa at nyu and she
teaches acting um oh cool she's we're an
actually talented one she's just at her
old high school like she teaches high
school kids and so in chicago in l.a we
were in l.a in high school in l.a so we
all kind of found it at our own
pace you know in our own time
um did your parents have any creative
were they surprised by that is there
anything
any acting
gene in in them you know they weren't my
my dad was a real and was a real
magnetic guy really big personality he
was in um he was in uh
real estate he did like commercial and
industrial real estate but so he wasn't
a performer but he was just kind of a
magnetic
person
but we didn't like grow up around show
business yeah we just kind of like
learned on the fly in in real time life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition
six young men vibed for the affection of
miriam rivera a beautiful model from
mexico but when miriam revealed that she
was a trans woman during the show's
finale the on-screen drama sparked an
international uproar about gender
sexuality and whether reality television
had finally gone too far follow harsh
reality the story of miriam rivera on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wandery plus in apple podcasts or the
wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
uh okay there's a lightning round okay
what is your most commonly used emoji
thumbs up or fist bump
yeah uh the one coming at the screen at
the screen i'm using a thumb bump that's
that's my trio and yellow you you stay
yellow i say yellow i see yellow me too
if you could be if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
um i would say i mean i enjoy playing i
really enjoy playing um pickleball i've
played a pickleball so i think there's a
small but burgeoning professional
pickleball tour i think i could really
make a name for myself on or my son
has really gotten into it pulled me into
um f1 racing i think maybe like uh but
yeah yeah those guys are like those guys
like international men of mystery they
travel all over and yeah they're awesome
oh [ __ ] fred now now you're forcing me
to ask you about austin powers really
quick and and do a little detour
in sure sure
uh do people say that
was was that imp that's gotta be heavily
improvised the mole mole the mole that
it was definitely part of it you know
that mole was definitely thoughtfully
you know that was part of it but this i
did a scene
with uh
my first day was with him and michael
york and beyonce
and that was that was the extent of it
but then they brought me back
for a sec for the second scene where he
goes molly molly and great yeah like
that was weeks after the first one and i
think they went in
um knowing that they wanted to do more
with it so it was like
to do more with it but that was that was
one that was very hard to keep a
straight face on
very difficult bets
well
you did a hell of a job um
uh that's really funny pickleball that's
our first pickleball answer um and
where's that effort formula one yeah
that's the 15 year old
uh the 15 year old really an f1 loves
driving loves can't wait to drive loves
drivers
uh as a parent it doesn't actually like
he's gonna get his permit in a few
months um his learner's permit but i
feel like uh that's all like uh very
controlled and yeah if he's listening to
this he's probably like shut up dude
yeah i know i know that in my dad's head
yeah
no i think
he's a good kid he i'm not worried about
him he'll be he's good he's good i can't
believe i'm your first pickleball answer
i mean that's just a sport of the future
and um i really encourage everyone to
get on board uh train's leaving the
station guys i can't believe well this
has not caught fire what do people say
baseball come on my only point of
reference is that my mother every couple
of years my mother gets really into the
idea of doing something like yeah when
we were kids it was like it was guitar
and then rollerblading and then
a couple years ago she wanted to get a
skull you know one of those skulls
and then she'll get the thing and then
she she uses it maybe once maybe twice
and then it sits there so her thing now
is pickleball she's been talking about i
live near a tennis court and she's like
oh i really want to get a pickleball
she's been saying for months i i i play
with lots of people's moms
[Music]
it makes me feel like i'm really going
to enjoy retirement when i get there
yeah i think that about certain things i
think about um i see people golfing and
for the first time in my life i think oh
god that looks kind of enjoyable i've
never golfed in my life but um it's when
you know you're getting old if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life fred what would it be
i just i love chips chips and salsa
chips and salsa forever have a
particular is there a restaurant you
want to shout out that has your favorite
i like i i like the supermarket
yeah okay
i like this supermarket
ralph's
[Music]
the oilier and saltier the better yeah
and i like a nice salsa um but yeah
chips and salsa if i could just have
that forever i would be very happy
likewise and i like the kind of basic
salsa i don't like the chunky stuff
there's a place in austin called paulvos
polvo's in austin that is um
did that it's just the best basic chips
and salsa i i miss it
oh good yeah what is your favorite what
was the movie that you talking about
these movies that you did that your kids
watched um
what was a movie that you were really
excited to introduce them to when they
were children a movie that was maybe
important to you as a kid
oh my gosh i have so many i have a whole
list of movies to watch with the kids
and so like whenever there's down time
we go to the list oh that's so cute
that's so great uh you know so i mean
everything from
you know like i showed them i just
showed them trying to find
yeah
um uh i just showed him spinal tap oh
wow awesome uh you know i just watched
like amadeus with my son yeah which i
love totally i remember saying like
it's great i remember seeing that my dad
took me to the theater to see that movie
oh really yeah i mean awesome yeah i'm a
big godfather fan i love watching the
godfather with them oh wow i used to
watch the hustler with my dad i loved
sharing that with them
so uh we're a big movie watching this
family and so yeah i just there's so
many movies i just love uh
just sharing with them and watching like
through their eyes the first time
and seeing how they'll either love it
you know like or or or not like it i'm
like oh you don't you're not they're not
into this or they'll watch like i was
watching all about eve yeah and my
eight-year-old was just sitting there on
the couch with me just sat up next to
the couch i was watching it not really a
movie you think a eight-year-old love
he's eaten probably see like popcorn's
like
it's good moving me oh like he was
amazing
so good it felt so good yeah i mean i i
love that um
they're into some stuff and not in
others
it's funny it's funny because this
something that people really
pass down yes um and it's pretty pretty
special to be a part of something
um what is your go-to karaoke song if
you were to sing karaoke
uh islands in the stream is a big one i
like a duet yeah i like a duet would you
sing with your audience
uh no no no
um she doesn't wouldn't doesn't like
that okay um doing anything with me or
or performing or doing things
so i would say that's the secret
yeah don't go breaking my heart is a big
one oh yeah uh like um
and then uh i like i like uh
air supply i like doing air supply i'd
love to see that
um yeah who was your very first
celebrity crush we were talking about
um how many people probably have crushes
on
you you're probably the answer to a lot
of people or someone on your show
why
uh i was like a big sports illustrated
swimsuit sure edition person
um and uh
and so
yeah like that that era that era the
kathy ireland mcpherson yes uh era yeah
cheryl t cheryl teagues may be a little
we're about the same age i'm trying to
remember my first that was a little
before yeah it was like
yeah uh like those yeah those those kind
of like early 90s yes claudius schiffers
yep yep um those those those are my
early childhood questions for sure um if
you had to get a tattoo
uh what would you get and where
uh
yes i think
i've oh like i my kids do not want to
get
want me to get a tattoo whenever i want
to tear up my kids i tell them i'm going
to get a tattoo they
say absolutely not
um
they're going to love this
the only time i thought about it was if
i was going to get something like maybe
my dad's initials or something something
something to remind me of my dad
that's the only thing i i think that
that really yeah i think i would i would
like to revisit that no sense yeah um
what is your favorite fruit
oh i really like uh a stone fruit i'm a
real seasonal fruit guy i really like
like a like a peach or a great nectarine
oh fresh cherries
i love a stone fruit yes oh man
nectarines now i've just been talking
way too much about this on a podcast uh
on any anything in in life i'm talking
too much about it but lately i'm in mess
i'm been in massachusetts the last few
weeks and the nectarines are in season
now and they're
it's a whole different experience
yeah yeah i really enjoy a summer fruit
that being said winter time comes i love
a pear i love a nice i like a nice white
bartlett pear yeah
um
who would you want to play you in your
biopic
uh i honestly i i think i'm looking
maybe you oh
i i i would be honored
um
i think i could do it just because i've
seen so much of your work
i mean i feel like your heart would be
in the right place totally oh i would do
it like such yes
yeah
it would be it would be in in in really
really fine hands who's your favorite
muppet
um animal oh yeah that's been
yeah my that's been pretty consistent
the animal is incredible what did you
get and the sweet and the swedish chef
always made me laugh
he made me laugh he did a bit and i
still remember it was one of the hardest
i've ever laughed when he was doing the
dough and
he throws the dough up and he pulls out
a gun and he shoots it oh yeah he
catches it and he says it goes donut and
i oh
i still remember
it was
so funny
um
yeah animal and the swedish chefs
there's that's the great thing about the
muppets is that there was um there was
true absurdist like adult comedy that
was just done with puppets so it was
like being absorbed by kids it was
brilliant what is your go-to pizza
topping
i like a pure i'm either going to go
just pure cheese i like a pure cheese or
because then i just want i want to know
you can do that i know exactly i don't
like to jazz it up yeah what i mean i
want to do that uh-huh that's the
baseline
that was a real test for pizza
yeah or and this is sacrilege and in
some circles might not not even be
considered pizza and i accept that is uh
like a white pizza oh you know no no no
no with like with like you know with
like ricotta cheese and um you know just
like like a pizza
more like what would people say like oh
no that's more like a focaccia or like
more of a flatbread situation you know
there are purists that i ex that i
respect and who's passionate about food
i respect yeah so i allow you know that
that might not even be considered pizza
well especially in chicago coming from
chicago i mean i mean there's chicago
people who says who you know who think
new york pizza is on a pizza on a
cracker there's people who you know who
say oh uh new york pizza chicago pizza
that's
that's that's a meal that's like almost
like a lasagna that's not even a pizza
and i i understand
i understand both yeah i understand both
that to me they're different such
different types of things i mean like
the
i i remember the first time i had
chicago pizza and it's such an
experience but it's it's a doughy it's
such a different experience so just
doughy it's a very doughy indulgence
saucy yeah affair yeah um but i i think
there's
as long as people are
talking passionately about food
do you prefer dogs or cats fred
um
dogs yeah i was not i'm not i was not a
pet person at all
at all
and my kids wanted a dog
and i was like my daughters would write
me these letters about why she should
have a dog
really so she's like when can i have a
dog
and i and my wife's a big dog person and
i want my kids to be a dog person
because i feel like i am deficient like
in my personality you don't want to pass
that off
and i don't i want them to be like
better than you i don't want them to
evolve
and so um
so my daughter's like when can i get a
dog
and she was like five so i picked like
the furthest time out that i could
possibly imagine and i'm like when
you're 10. and then like i blinked and
she was 10. she goes can i get that dog
and oh my god i guess we have to get
this gone she remembered and so my god
she told me all the time and so uh
we got a dog and it is
the love of my life oh that's awesome
it's opened it's like you're on the
grinch and they're like his heart was
three three sizes that day that's me on
my desk i have a group shout out to my
family holding up uh yes
wait and then look at this that's this
is where my heart is
like
we got to put that on instagram that's
uh these are the two photos this is my
family and i love my family my wife has
very small foot but then look at the
surface area of the dawn that's great
that's so good
we have to put that on instagram that's
a really funny she's the love of my life
wha what's what's her name fred
freda friday frida who named her
my daughter
she's uh has all these books and would
read when she was younger and still does
about you know
you know strong women you know and women
in history and women sophia was she
loved that name from frida kahlo from
one of her books well that's got a
machine number too
yeah you have a 10 year old who is aware
of frida kahlo
yeah that's exactly what's amazing
um her middle name is uh also uh
booboo jeffries oh okay
okay after another great woman in
history yes after this honeybee because
i'm a i'm a good parent and i'm a
terrible parent booboo jeffries is um
the name of a character that tiffany
haddish played when she hosted saturday
night live
so
this is
and and like i watched that out loud
with my kids so i wanted to show the
kids i watched snl oh did you show them
yours
um
not not out there not out there
like you go on you go on like the where
it is i don't know if it's on hulu or
netflix and you go and find it and
it goes back like
not that far
not far enough for old friends oh that's
it's funny you're like this you're like
my age you're like a young but you're
like a salty old veteran who i'm a salty
old veteran yeah um and uh technology
hasn't caught up yet
with casual
episode in delivering that oh my god
that's funny that's really funny do your
kids harbor any ambitions to be active
are they do they have that gene
they've all grown up like around sets
you know they've been kind of set since
they were little so desensitized to it
they're probably like
they love it though like i think my
daughter really wants to be a director
oh cool um my son writes i think he
wants he wants to write he's always
writing things and saying to me
my youngest my eight-year-old he uh
i think might be the performer but
they're all they're all hilarious yeah
great personalities and well they're all
not great fred as
as thrilling as it is to get to talk to
you and um talk about these you know
these your career i it's so nice it's so
nice to see you just seem like somebody
who really loves
their life and being a their family and
and
you know you see you seem so content and
happy with as a family man and that
makes makes me happy it's so nice to see
i i am i love i love my family i love my
kids i love my dog yeah like that it's
definitely apparent
um i uh i but uh no i i feel
very fortunate for everything and and
even more so that um i get you know i'm
also doing something as you are and we
all are in this business that i really
love and have been allowed to do it for
this many years is uh yeah i feel very
very very fortunate and uh for for all
of it and i i don't have to tell you
that i'm a fan you've
been i've made that abundantly clear
it's great it's great i appreciate it so
much it really does it means it means a
lot and uh and i i um
i appreciate you inviting me on here oh
man it means a lot and and the fact
you're such a
genuine uh
fan is it's very very very meaningful
yeah thank you well thank you fred this
is big for us so um thanks for thanks
for taking the time
so that happened that happened oh you're
doing fred
who are you doing oh i was trying to do
daniel stern oh oh oh so that happened
uh wow fred savage oh man legend what a
guy and what a guy like what a guy what
a guy that's pretty good that's pretty
good maybe the nicest guy i know and and
he seems like the nicest guy i was like
looking at him when he was saying those
things about his kids and about and i
couldn't detect a shred of like like a
false note i
he seemed so sincere wow and it was like
moving that and i met that when i said
like it's so nice to see because like
really like i do feel like as i'm sure
you do i feel like i know him as a kid i
feel like i saw him kind of grow up a
little bit so weird to hear as well it's
like
i can't
tell you how weird it was hearing you
talk to him because in my mind it's like
how the [ __ ] does justin know
kevin arnold well remember when because
he sound he
sounds a bit like
kevin arnold season five of that show
he's got that like post-puberty adult
sounding voice but he still sounds like
kevin arnold i know you it's like it was
like blowing my mind listening to that
well i i had similar experiences with uh
well once when i first talked to fred
which was years ago did you remember
this when we because christian i wrote
this with our friend kier we wrote a
script and we were looking for someone
to direct it
and
it's fred
like wanted to i don't think his
schedule worked out i i for whatever
reason he ended up not but i
uh we talked to him about it and you
talked to him i talked to him and and i
remember just being so
struck by his voice i was so distracted
by how familiar it was that like it was
kind of difficult to
have a real conversation with him i i i
just kept
it kept surprising me that i was yeah
talking to him that's how i listened to
this every every five minutes i would
think
i can't believe he he's talking about
him this is great it's like blowing my
mind just like such a like you said such
a huge part of our childhood i know and
i had it both with danica mckellar and
with dan laurie i worked with a little
bit and and dan it was more surprising
because he was so different and not so
different in person but you know he was
just kind of like laid back in person
and really nice but like he wasn't like
kevin on kevin you know he had he didn't
have that gruff dad i mean
yeah he played that part so well it was
almost like he reminded me of the pop
and berenstain bears like yeah bad bear
a little bit like he was a real just he
reminded me of my dad yeah he's papa
bear and he had this i saw him on a
plane once and i was like i'll really
walk by him yeah like man legends well
that's why i was trying to
get asked kevin kevin oh boy i was
trying to ask fred that about you know
what his experience is like walking in
the world but
you know he he had such a healthy
perspective he had such a good attitude
about it that
not that not that to be freaked out by
that or to to
like acknowledge the weirdness of it
would would be a bad attitude but he i
was just so curious like because i i
knew how i felt around him and i can
only imagine
that so many other people feel that way
about fred savage about because like we
followed his upbringing in a way i mean
it was that that's how it feels
sometimes yeah but maybe i mean here's
the theory it's like being a friend
maybe we're old enough at this point
like the people who grew up watching the
wonder years are now old enough so that
they're kind of past
this stage of like
being giddy around him if they see him
they're a little bit more mature
right until just now until you talk to
her fangirled out i'm sure i'm sure i
don't know i don't know but like people
must do that but it didn't sound like
uh well like he said i mean people liked
that care i mean it's an understatement
but people like that character yeah so
people just have like warm positive
uh memories about it so like anyone who
does come up to him is really i never
feel threatened or anything because yeah
that's true that people
feel connected to him and like
appreciative of him yeah that was really
interesting and that his kids witnessed
that too so his kids aren't like
super into the business part they're
certainly not into like trappings of
fame which is like oh that's just like a
weird part of dad's life also
i would suspect that the two main
reasons that he
um
that it didn't really go to his head as
a kid and he was kind of blind to a lot
of that fame stuff well one is that his
family and his friends he was like i
didn't have any right friends in show
business and my family wasn't in it and
so he was like on quote unquote normal
kid right but also his pre-social media
which you guys talked a bit about like
imagine a difference
that show and that experience for him
would have been
with instagram with twitter with tick
tock i mean that's it would have been a
totally different experience and he
might have grown up to be a pretty
different guy that's really interesting
to think about that's true
i mean and and then when you apply that
to everyone even people outside the
entertainment business right you know
how different
people are going to be the next with
this new this technology yeah it's like
that's but that but like he's an
interesting example of like how
different i know could have been for him
and the benefits of avoiding that kind
of stuff i loved hearing about the like
bts of the wonder years and like how he
watched movies with dan lauria i know
it's so cool it's like so trippy to
think about and my old man used to oh my
god yeah and also
the uh
the onset narrator that they had i know
in place of that
that was i know that's so interesting
how they did that so they had someone
who was like not just reading the
narration someone like performs
i know it makes me want to like watch
some of those again and see if i can
because sometimes i it does kind of make
sense that that was the case you know
because you can sort of like
see them feeling yeah narration and then
the cynical part of me thought
god i wonder if that onset narrator is
really jealous i thought that daniel
started i thought that and i wonder if
he resents him i thought that it's like
he does all this great work when it's
like you know happening also every take
he does he's just dubbed out
and then daniel stern goes in a booth
like once a week or whatever and just
like knocks it all out yeah i'd be
interested to know that guy's
perspective yeah well
but also
i mean but also you got to have the
experience i mean talk about an
experience being live well for every
shot of the wonder yeah i'm someone who
loves i mean i'm i love acting i mean to
me that would be what a thrill that
would you just to be doing it we talk
about this a lot on the show it's like
yes there's the ego element um is always
going to be involved but to minimize it
i mean like best case scenario that guy
you know in a very pure way
might think well like what you just said
i got to be there i got to perform and i
love performing i got to perform with
other great actors and and um so what so
i mean it's the doing of it uh that is
the the real you just turned my cynicism
around oh well i don't know i mean i
don't know but that's a really like
positive uh glass half full kind of
that's how i would that's how i would
aspire to yeah feel about that kind of
job um two little
nitpicky things
if i may
um my brother always knew exactly when
one
i kind of wish you had asked him even
though he talked about
like kind of what interested him in
directing he thought like the mechanics
of it seemed so cool
i'm curious what
why he
ultimately pursued that as a career over
acting huh
yeah
yeah because he had such a successful i
know child acting career and he seemed
i'm sure he enjoyed it
and he was on this great show and these
great movies that i wonder why after
going to college he wasn't like i want
to like
continue my acting i i have a guess okay
when you do it so successfully at at
that age and then
you start you keep doing it i mean he's
like
we talked about some of those other
things rules of attraction whatever but
but when it's not as consistent and then
you have a family i'm sure you want more
like directing jobs offer real
more stability i think and like
consistency anyway that's why our friend
friend of the show's best friend show
jerry o'connell is pursuing that now and
and that's why frankly it interests me
you know i i would love to to do
stability stability and like um and not
have and getting out of the hustle
there's a hustle to acting that is um
that it's just different i know there is
to directing as well but there's
something about the acting hustle that
is that's true uniquely um
uh
challenging i think also he's i think
you're right and also he mentioned
that as a kid he didn't
have any training he didn't right so he
his acting as a kid was just like
was just uh very pure and he just like
yeah
existed
at in the moment and was like
like honest yeah but
maybe he never wanted to take that next
step of like well now i'm gonna dump
after and i need to like exactly really
dive in train and that he alluded to he
did he did and and i don't want to
mention this person by name but i i saw
a movie last night with a former child
actor in it and and
they just they didn't make that next
step i mean in terms of their skill set
they they were
you know
cute or whatever and like out there was
an honesty there was a purity to the
performance when they were a kid but
once he he talks about it it's really
like i guess is it puberty or what it's
around that time when you're when you're
developing and you're becoming more
self-aware
um that sometimes
hurts acting i mean like
the goal
of an actress to to let go of that
self-awareness yeah and kids have that
natural yes some and some kids can just
do that on camera i mean that's the
that's the rare thing that he had right
right and like haley john
yeah brilliant kid actors right are like
not acting that's the irony of the whole
thing it's like the best actors don't
you don't see them acting yes like and
like and that's rare for a kid like most
kids are like quote-unquote child actors
you see them all the time these like
little stage kids you see them acting
exactly hi there my name is jimmy and
yeah you never saw with him right and
some of these other like great kids it
looks like they're just existing yeah
yeah they're just like being honest
it's pretty wild he was an amazing kid
amazing and and also to have that
success and to not
he also wasn't he clearly was not into
the
of the trappings he clearly wasn't into
like
that stuff the fame and all he he talks
about that without sounding without
bragging about it which is uh it made it
sound so much more yeah
um so i i think it's that i think it's
like he see and he's smart you know went
to stanford really articulate there is
um
he and he has a cure he had a curiosity
about
that i i guess we don't have to ask him
now okay
would have been a waste of time uh the
other slight nitpicky thing and i may
have misheard you but you said her name
twice
uh you were saying abby mills i believe
oh the mom
it's allie miller yeah i said abby i'm
pretty sure i could write no no i think
you said it twice and and he didn't
correct you but i felt a little like uh
uh she's such a good actress
like correct the record you're right
allie mills great actress god she's so
good both of them those parents dan
laurie and ali ali mills yeah um it's
funny when you
were like you're talking about michael
landis and playing kirk mcrae
and it's i mean it's crazy to me and
it's crazy to you that their kids are
friends they know sports together and
they see each other at like pta meetings
and whatever and you're like isn't that
crazy you're like do people think that's
crazy that you're like
uh kevin arnold and kirk mcrae are
hanging out and their kids are friends
and he was like i don't think so i think
just you would think that's crazy
but as he said that i was like no i
would think that's great yeah yeah
and then becky's like blowing my mind
oh my god oh yeah it's so weird that
it's like a generation has passed and
now his kids are i think he said they're
15 13 and eight
and it's like oh those are basically the
ages of
kevin arnold and his siblings everyone
he's like the father now it's so i know
and now there's a new version of the
show that it's so weird it's just like a
generation has gone by it's specifically
that show that i get really weird around
people from but just because it was i
mean it really was like whenever i see
an actor like
every once in a while i ran into carla
guccino and who saw like this sweet like
it's just the nicest br like
so cool and um but i i find myself
getting a little like
whoa oh my god that's good i mean she's
also really beautiful i know i know and
so when she's on the wonder years she
was like the prettiest girl she was ever
yeah yeah maybe ever maybe still is
maybe yeah um hopefully futurecast that
was funny yeah when you asked him who
his first crush was and he was like ah
let's see it was the early 90s it was so
weird since it's like you imagine yeah
it's winnie kevin arnold he's in the
early 90s like no but he's like oh it's
like the sports ice cream so you picture
like
kevin arnold being into sports
illustrated swimsuit model instead of
like this like some somebody from the
60s you know like welsh or somebody it's
so funny like no no that's that was a
different era yeah you like can't
separate i like couldn't i mentally
can't separate fred savage from kevin i
was like how do you know kathy ireland
that's weird
should we read a letter yeah yeah
okay this is from
jackie peter
peter subspell p-a-t-e-r
it could be potter potter
father
pretentious yeah uh means father in
latin yeah potter is that how you spell
it p-a-t-e yeah
um subject misheard lyrics
hi guys my name is jackie and it's
j-a-c-k-i-e there there's no chance that
that's a man is it
or i did there is a chance jackie slater
was a man oh yeah
jackie or all hayley yeah
huh okay hopefully future guest i know
if if only to talk to him about uh
yeah life life
another great child actor yes you know
who then later yeah you're that's a
what a story that is i think he had
totally quit the business jackie or halo
and they found him we'll save it for the
uh
yeah okay episode um
okay back to jackie peter or potter or
potter my name is jackie or jack hey no
there's no accent and i want to thank
you for filling my ears with your
laughter and entertainment it really
helps brighten my day ah thanks jackie
it's it really is a pleasure you know
when people say that it's a pleasure but
this is a true pleasure don't you think
it sure is sorry i was distracted by
your squeaky i'm sorry i know [ __ ]
that we'll stop moving around so much or
we get it fixed all right get in we'll
get a new chair
okay
i wanted to point out a missed
opportunity when you talked with sarah
bareilles
i let you know how much i loved missed
opportunities pointed out
i never dwell on those
uh okay here comes jackie's
admonishment or just whatever
you had stopped asking the question
which golden girl do you must identify
with in the lightning round and i was so
curious to hear her reaction because
she's the granddaughter to the late
great b arthur wait who is what wait who
is sarah bareilles she is i wonder what
she would have said
i don't think that's true god wait let
me i'm gonna go i wish i had known that
i don't think that's true well i just
believe everything i read so as far as
i'm concerned right now it's the truth
according to jackie um be arthur the
granddaughter that's wild uh jackie also
i'm dying to know what the heck your
intro song lyrics are hello hello again
shaboom banana please be our friend
friend i don't think that's accurate
well you know according to sorry to
interrupt according to google i it
doesn't seem like b arthur is the
grandmother of the late uh be arthur is
not the greatest i wonder what mother of
cerebrals i don't
i just googled their names together and
like nothing came up oh weird so that it
would have oh jackie has an inside like
maybe she's a maybe words for like
ancestry well let's put a pin on that
okay parties is are they related yeah
way in in the uh
where is it facebook yeah facebook yeah
um okay when i was a kid i'd be singing
in the back to jackie when i was a kid
i'd be singing in the back seat put the
penny in the dress to elton john's benny
in the chats because that's what i
thought it sounded like some things
never changed that's funny
there's a show i think about that like
misheard lyrics i was just listening to
wait can i just confess something about
the lyrics to shaboom yeah theme song
yeah i don't know i don't i've never i
i'm really i'm with her i
never know what they say
i can't believe i never looked it up but
i don't know what they are well
it's like literally there's something
something tells me that jackie doesn't
have access to google
because she would have uh that be arthur
thing would have been
but i'm ashamed that i've never taken
the time to look this up and i've always
been curious about it oh really and i'm
on the show yeah that's true i'm on the
show
and i don't know what the lyrics are
it's like fred savage not knowing the
lyrics to with a little help from my
friends i guess what what would you do
if i
let out a poo
arguably worse for us because we have to
listen to the show he doesn't have to
watch the wonder years
i should have asked him that too
he had a couple favorite episodes you
watch every week with your family like
he must have watched this that's a good
question and and his brother ben that
would have been a good question that's
before ben met the world um shaboom hey
nani what oh hey nani ding dong a lang a
lang a lang boom just be a different
verse go to the next verse
okay uh oh life could be a dream shaboom
if i could take you up in paradise oh no
no that's a different song right no oh
yeah that's the song different verse if
i could take you up in paradise up above
shaboom if you could if you would tell
me i'm the only one that you love life
could be a dream sweetheart hello hello
again shaboom and hoping we'll meet
again that's it okay hello hello again
shaboom and hoping we'll meet again and
hoping we'll meet again yeah i i love
that song
it is such a you know it was hoping
we'll meet again i know that never made
sense to me do you know where i heard
that song it gave me the idea to uh to
try to get it as the theme was um i was
watching this john waters movie uh
crybaby oh right johnny depp i remember
and amy lokan another
childhood crush of mine who went on to
you had a lot of crushes i did um and
hoping we'll meet again oh i'm so glad i
know that yeah thanks thank you for
pointing that out cheering up with the
arthur thing even if it's wrong i'm i'm
curious like where that i i'm always
curious where like rumors came from yeah
like the richard gere thing it might be
right i didn't mean to say she's wrong
just because i didn't see anything when
i googled it right away you know the
richard gere thing uh the gerbil what no
how he was supposed to do tough shots
i just got nervous
um okay here we go uh the other betting
the jets put the penny that put the
penny and the dress that's funny
you know what elton john's song i'd love
and could never if there were certain
lyrics in it that i
was unclear on and i re-watched almost
famous the other night it was um tiny
dancer
oh well then
hold me closer tony danza oh yeah
count the headlights on the highway uh
lay me down laying me down and ch and
cheats of splenda i'm not good with
lyrics in general i mean obviously i
don't know the lyrics of our theme song
but yeah i've always had a hard time
with lyrics anyway do you have any song
lyrics that you thought were right but
turned out to be way wrong yeah it's
funny we're kind of talking about it um
i feel like something happens to me all
the time
too um
oh you know the one thing that's jumping
out blinded by the oh yeah wrapped up
like a douche i used to think it was
douche
forever forever in me too until someone
told me it was deuce for a while i
thought it was douche
it was a different type of douche like
it was because i've you know i was so
certain that it was douche that i mean
in fairness they clearly said douche
wrapped up like a douche in the yeah
it's so cool it's not deuce yeah it's
not a mumbly part of the song is that i
know it was covered but wasn't
originally
well i know manfred mann's earthband
which is a crazy that's the band yeah i
don't know if they did it originally or
they have a version of it can you look
that up blinded by the light yeah i
think
he
i thought that was a springsteen song
originally
i think it was oh yeah no um uh man oh
no maybe not maybe it was man from man's
earth band
who sang blind and by the light
originally
okay
see this is what you need to get jackie
um
blinded by the light is a song written
and recorded by bruce springsteen oh yes
which first appeared in the 973 i have
greetings from okay oh that's a great
album uh and then i guess man for men's
earth band did a cover
uh yeah i can't believe you knew manford
man's ear
springs well you know why when i was
getting into rock and roll i um
i
that version for whatever reason was the
one that i would hear all the time and
and i i remembered that you know it's
such a memorable sounding name band name
manfred mann's earthband i also used to
think it was like a really funny weird
name for a band it just stuck in my head
it's stuck in my crawl craw craw
craw oh we've done this before i think
it's crawl uh-oh so you know what i
think i think crosstalk space i know
we've talked about this
we're running out of things
i don't know if we talked about it on
the show oh really we've definitely
talked about it though oh yeah we're on
the show yeah we're still on the show
it's still happening yeah
um sincerely jackie peter like later
with a p
oh peter oh wow yeah well thanks for
clarifying that jackie yeah for all you
uh
pronunciation haters paters
um and she's from uh or he is from
auburndale florida auburndale where is
that i don't know it's a third thing in
this letter though we gotta look up
though uh thank you jackie that that was
a really good letter interesting and and
now i'm you know what sucks is like and
this happens to me a bunch
whenever i'm working whenever there's
like an improv scene where i do this
where i think like later something will
pop into my head like [ __ ] i should have
said this um but now i'm going to be
thinking of
these lyrics that i've gotten wrong over
the years are going to keep popping into
my head well that's why it was a good
thought-provoking letter yes i'll be
thinking about it if you guys want to
write good thought-provoking letters our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com and we would like to thank
our very special guest fred savage who
uh just blew my childhood mind mind okay
um god i don't want to inject any of
that
that
inject yeah boy uh yeah but that was a
time of innocence and we should we
should end the show in a more innocent
way well i was trying sorry
um
uh it was the last straw for me i looked
at my brother and i just knew that
it's hard to even like uh make jokes
about that because the writing was so
good it's brilliant it's really it was
poe it was like real poetry it's
brilliant and i
sincerely hope the new incarnation of
the show is brilliant or at least good
because i'm excited to watch it and uh
you guys should all check it out because
fred directed the pilot as my brother's
voice began to wind down i had the
sinking feeling that this might be the
best moment of the day um oh boy we'll
talk to you guys next week thanks for
watching uh-oh listening uh oh it's a
podcast that's right i forgot oh we're
recording this still yeah okay cool wow
people are lucky lucky listeners they're
really hanging in there
yeah what are you doing still listening
oh yeah there's the end credits and then
the very special voice memo right stay
tuned
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life for short is hosted by me
justin long it's produced by my brother
my friend and my co-producer christian
long it's also produced by megan the e
monaco senior producer is michelle
mieshlands audio engineer is sergio
enriquez and executive producer marshall
louis for wondering bye to everyone
listening wherever you may be listening
with friends or family
[Music]
getting an ice cream truck as an adult i
feel like
i think i might feel
i feel like you're weird disgusting or
something yeah or uh but i feel like a
deviant i mean it's like swimming in a
kiddie pool yeah yeah imagine we're like
going like a in a bubble hop house you
know like one of those like bouncy
houses but see at least that
uh there's something that physically
doesn't make sense about that guru's too
big for that we're too big for a kiddie
pool we're too big for a bounce house
yeah but adults don't buy ice cream ice
cream drop that's true but it's still
weird i was still just as weird as being
in a kitty pool i think to me
yeah i would look down on an adult at an
ice cream truck especially if you were
in a line with just kids well you'd look
like a parent and if somebody was like
you look like a parent
you